first off manure 50 year old husband
comes in and says he wants to start a
stop and just take him to rehab just
right away just take him if anyone wants
to start a ska band today take
them to rehab bad time
[Music]
sorry guys uh podcast I'll keep it alive
please give it up for mr. Greg baron
everybody I love this show and I love
the idea that that you have an
experience really like this is not
happening right like just this is
up you know we all have those stories I
mean I have a ton of them when I'm not
telling today I saw the penis of the
drummer from a town like at a show
that's not no I mean like you can't wrap
your head or anything around it it's
huge but also sometimes you forget that
you're the thing that's happening to
somebody else like you're the oh
my god this is not happening like you're
the event that somebody goes you so
I would like to tell you a story that
has both of those elements and it
involves my sobriety which I have today
and I've had since 1996 except for that
two times I got high which so that then
it's not since night I broke it but
that's because the that's not the rules
so you don't get to just leave where you
can and I have
but what time it was my decision and
then the other time it was also my
decision so the first story the first
story is this one so my wife and I we
had a 19 year old dog okay 19
year old German Shepherd that is
old like that is that's done like that
dog is done like it literally
just sat in the corner of a room it was
like a pillow with bones in it
and a head it just sat there like the
dog wanted to be done do you understand
Lee was just being kept alive on pills
that's it he just gave it pills to
keep it alive and you know
they're they don't you know
there's not oh they are dumb but they're
not that dumb you know what I mean like
the dog was just like you could just
tell it was like dude haven't we
done this haven't I dog this out of
it what the do you want from me
I've got the ball remember that I
got a bunch of times as I recall and I
on the carpet and ruin that
whole birthday party thing and
then I took a picture for your
Instagram please
what the more do you want from me
right but you don't kill it because it's
a dog so like here take these pills just
give it a lot of pills right so anyway
we had this dog and it was very old and
and it was being kept alive on pills so
and I didn't know what the pill I didn't
pay any attention to what the pills were
I mean I had there was one the dog had
no moves left right except for that they
accept it would fart right I just don't
you know I mean but their buttholes are
all worked out so it's just you don't
even know what's happened you know their
buttholes are all loose so it's a whoo
it just comes out it's like a cloud Oh
like it just oh oh just a ghost farts
just a whistle
like you don't know it's there until you
know it's there and then you're
pissed because dog farts are like like
you know some smells but you go but dog
farts make you piss like you're like
wrong with you so anyway uh there
was one Christmas I love Christmas
I love I like Christmas so much
I'm gonna make you hate it
that's how much I like it I'm that guy I
like it so much i ruin it for my whole
family which is up cuz i have
kids anyway so i have that it's
Christmas and I'm over excited about it
and I'm also depressed because I have
depression and anxiety which I'm not
aware of and also there was a sweater I
wanted and I'm not getting it
like even my wife said you're not
getting it I might be like in a surprise
way or I'm not getting it and
not in a surprise way and then she's
like this should be about the kids
you I my god you're the catalog and then
she's like I don't know what a catalog
is because I live in the now the point
is
I was very upset and it was Christmas
Eve and I was sort of I was having a
panic attack and feeling shitty and not
to get too dark but I was feeling
suicidal I was struggling with some
mental health issues that I didn't know
that I had an anxiety and and then all
of a sudden I remembered that one day
when my friend was in the house he had
walked past the dog pills and he had
noticed that one of the jars of pills
was like a homework oh yeah those
you know I mean he didn't say what they
were but he made a face that went that's
good like there's something in those
pills that might be something a
depressed person should take on
Christmas Eve so there were two jobs
they know and that dog pills come in
like little tiny jugs like tankards not
the tall orange ones so thanks for
clearing that up Greg you're welcome I
walked past the dog pills I remember
that one of them is potent apparently
and I'm not sure which because I also
know the other ones for the butthole so
I don't want to take I don't want to
take the wrong one my butthole is tight
and I mean I don't need a really
my sphincter is good enough I don't need
to really you know what I mean it's for
a dog that has anyway so then there's a
there's a there's a on one of the jugs
there's the sleepy face guy do you know
the sleepy face guy on the pills right
he's like he's got like a nose and then
he's like oh he's so tired because he's
taking these pills and he's not allowed
to operate machinery do you know what
I'm talking about that guy if that guy's
on a jar pills tea if you want a
party but don't I'm saying no set drugs
but if you're depressed and you don't
know any better that's the one you go
for and also but why would a dogs pills
have a sleeping what do they what is it
they have to stay awake for do you not I
mean if your dogs operating any
machinery you don't understand pets at
all or you're missing a really
good financial opportunity because
your dog can drive a forklift so I take
one of the pills I'm not really sure
what it is but I take one of the pills
and then I read that you know and it
it's like a sweater for your
insides it's magical
it levels me out I'm like oh my god this
is amazing something called hydrocodone
right and i alcoholic I'm like I'm never
doing that again just the one time just
gonna do it the ones just the one next
week I'll take one other one later in
the month then two maybe five a day so
like an alcoholic drug addict I
escalated and by that then I was taking
seven a day and at that point I just
lost it one day here's a perfect
example one day I just showed up
in the kitchen in my own house with a I
cut myself a mohawk and told my wife I
was starting a ska band if that guys if
you first off manure fifty year old
husband comes in and says he wants to
start a stop and just take him to rehab
just right away just take him if anyone
wants to start a ska band today
take them to rehab bad time
bad time it's been played out alright so
I was super up and I did try and
start a stop and because and I'd quit my
other really reliable jobs comedy and
writing books so I'd given up those
opportunities my wife is very upset I
was a total mess they took me to
rehab so now I go to rehab
I pull my together I move back in
the house I can't live in the house they
put me in Iowa we have a guesthouse in a
garage I live in the garage if there's a
place on the other side but how yard I
lived in a closet on the other side of
the yard but I right good night
everybody
anyone so uh but I was living there but
I really was like okay I'm gonna pull it
together I got on the right kind of
medication and I figured out that I had
some problems and pulling my life
together and I'm feeling good and I kind
of missed the Scott band I really did
want to be a rock star you not I mean
but I had to give up the you know what I
mean not for I mean not that anyone
noticed but anyway so I start working on
my stand-up and my career I write a
one-man show I make friends with my wife
again just friends anyway I I get my
together and I'm feeling very good
about myself because now I'm not the
thing that happens to you right on the
guy experiencing life I'm not gonna ruin
people's lives I'm gonna be of service
I'm gonna be a good person I'm just
gonna
can just you know just take it day by
day have everything you know then things
are good my careers coming back my wife
likes me again I get asked to go to
Australia to perform for twenty two
nights in in Melbourne one-man show that
I've written very exciting careers on
the comeback got a big tour after that
it's all good I have a little
stomachache it's fine it's a little
stomachache I went to the doctor before
I left for Australia he said it was gas
that's not good doctoring when you find
out what it was eight shows into my run
in Australia
I'm on fire my insides are burning it's
awful I go to the doctor they give me
some drugs which I oh my gosh I remember
these they had to they had to give me
some drugs because I was in so much pain
I forgot even about drugs I forgot that
they're worth like I was in kill me pain
I was literally like the dog just end
this just ended I was in so much
pain
they gave me I don't know whatever some
sort of pain reliever and then they take
a photo of my insides and then they wake
me up and they say you have tumors in
your stomach you have cancer
I was I'm gonna come back so that's
what they said the effort you have a but
it was in Australia so I have to say and
I'm not saying get cancer I'm against it
I'm against cancer I just want to come
out right now and say I'm against cancer
I don't want you to get it should you
think you have it go to Australia to get
the diagnosis because just the way they
say cancer sounds a tiny bit less bad
that's all you can say it just goes up
at the end it just consumate there tends
to mate they say made a lot
it just feels cheerier like you're doing
it together hey kenza mate we all do
know you do anyway that cancer they told
me that I had it they thought I did that
I tumors of my stomach they weren't sure
what they were ever they were there was
a cluster of tumors it's really a lot of
ours a lot there's a lot of are you find
out there's a lot of ours in cancer
cluster tumor a lot of ours so III they
think I have cancer and they say you
have to go home and I was so high on
whatever it was they gave me I'm like to
my apartment in Australia no to America
you have to take your cancer home and
you have to take it home can't have it
there they don't want you to die in
there so so I I say alright and they
they say what you're gonna be in pain
until you get to the hospital you need
to get there within the next 72 hours
but here is a box of oxycontin I'm like
that could be a mistake a box not just a
few
box like with trays do you understand
we're talking about a street value of
about a million dollars to a drug addict
who's already hired from whatever's they
gave them I went out and bought a hat so
here's how high I was I had my manager
with me I said take the pills give them
to me and let's be responsible about
this I just want to get home I want to
see my family if I'm gonna die fair
enough but I just want to get home so I
go to the airport and everything's fine
except I accidentally put a knife in my
backpack that's you don't you're not
allowed to take a knife through customs
I don't know if I'm sharing anything new
with you guys but no knives at customs
on an international flight they don't
care for it so I had a knife in my
backpack and the lady goes she's very
nice and she said this sir this is a
knife and I said to her I have cancer
she literally goes I don't know what the
next sentence is like literally I don't
know what to say to you so she's like
well you still have to leave the knife
but I'll give you a hug so my my my
managers with me so that's my thing I'm
like just make sure that I don't overuse
the drugs because I could and because
I'm dying I probably don't care so make
me care and don't let me take all that
drugs because I don't wanna show up at
home being that guy so I get on the
airplane they stick my manager in
economy and they put me in first
class so I know I'm dying right I know
it's a make-a-wish thing put him in
first class but I the last time I'll be
on a plane so they throw him in
baggage and I'm sitting in a throne or
you know whatever it is just this
massive thing let's give you back rubs
and I'm sitting next to a guy who I
don't know who turns out to be this
drummer for the band Switchfoot
do you guys know Switchfoot at all yeah
that's usually the response again yeah
so anyway they're fine BAM they're fine
band I don't know them but I know who
they are but I don't know I know that I
know that they surf and I know they're
Christian and that's all they know
probably you couldn't sing a song but
the guys super nice the drummer and so
we start talking I say look I'm gonna
ask you a really weird favor but I'm
dying maybe probably and I have to take
these pills and would you give them to
me not let me take more than I need and
make sure I take them when I'm supposed
to and he said yeah sure I said thank
you also if I get up like if I rub your
chest or walk around the plane or
I don't have any of you ever been on
oxycontin but it's not bad it's yeah you
feel you're friendly and you like
conversations and you want to talk to
everyone about everything and you also
it has this amazing thing that never
happens to me in real life
yeah actually makes you want to listen
to people so like you're generally
interested in weird what kind of
buttons are those I'm on my shirt yeah
they seem neat all right anyway the guy
was super nice and I said would you make
sure I don't overuse these and then I
passed out and I slept the whole flight
you know and so we get to Los Angeles
and and so that's cool I'm sitting next
to you know got from a band that's neat
and he says let me walk you to baggage
claim so the drummer from Switchfoot
walks me to baggage claim gets my bags
for me and then he goes hey man I just
want to tell you that I love you I said
a prayer for you you're gonna be fine
and I was like wow and I bent down to
pick up my bags and I turned around and
he was gone gone not like Oh in a
crowd like there was nobody he
was gone I was like did I dream
that with these my last moments I had a
lucid dream why the guy from Switchfoot
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]